So what exactly happens at the medical exam?
You're getting a ton of questions
regarding the medical exam,
so in this video,
I'm gonna cover which vaccines you need to have,
what you should bring to your medical exam,
how to find the right doctor,
and what to do if you don't have access
to your vaccination record.
The purpose of the green card medical exam
is to ensure that the foreign spouse
seeking a green card has no health conditions
that could make them inadmissible to the United States.
Everyone applying for a green card
must submit their medical exam to the USCIS.
Couples sometimes think that any doctor
can perform this exam.
If you're applying from inside the United States,
you will need to see a civil surgeon
designated by the USCIS.
Just Google find USCIS doctor
and the first link will take you to the right place.
From there, you'll find a list of doctors
in your area based on your zip code.
For the most part,
all you need for this exam
is your vaccination record and your ID.
During the exam,
the doctor will screen you for communicable diseases,
drug abuse or addiction,
physical or mental disorders associated
with harmful behavior,
and conditions that make it impossible
for you to support yourself.
Remember, if you don't have your vaccination record,
the doctor will order a blood test
in order to see what vaccines you're missing.
Otherwise, here's a list of the vaccinations
that you're going to need. To have